ich habe gehört dass sie sich bei
Deutschland und bei Kanzler Olaf Scholz
bedankt haben hat sich ihr Verhältnis zu
Deutschland verändert ich höre das zum
ersten Mal dass sie Herrn Scholz Danke
sagen
ich habe Deutschland immer sehr positiv
bewertet weil ich die Unterstützung der
Gesellschaft von Anfang an gespürt habe
seitdem Beginn dieser edige
teamenbesatzung
im Wesentlichen hat die deutsche
Gesellschaft geschlossen die Wahl der
Ukraine bezogen auf den Kampf für ihre
Rechte und Freiheiten unterstützt und
meine persönliche Beziehung zu
Deutschland hat sich nicht geändert
eine Veränderung hat sich seitens des
Bundeskanzlers mir gegenüber und
umgekehrt vollzogen
ich glaube das ist ein positiver Moment
ich möchte dass dieser Trend anhält
ich bin der Meinung dass der Kanzler
jetzt mit dem Thema Krieg besser umgeht
selbstverständlich war er vor seinem
Amtsantritt ein Fachmann in der
Wirtschaft im Bankwesen in der Politik
schon muss Spezialisten
allerdings ist ein Krieg etwas ganz
anderes
er hat die ganze Zeit die Folgen des
Kriegs in den Vordergrund gestellt
und letztendlich hat er feststellen
müssen dass der russische Präsident das
eine behauptet und etwas anderes tut
[Musik]
ich meine jetzt nicht die offiziellen
Erklärungen der russischen Führung er
hat ja den Bundeskanzler und Herrn
macron was anderes versprochen
und dann fanden persönliche Gespräche
statt das Ergebnis war wieder ein ganz
anderes
ich denke das ist eine Frage des
Vertrauens
der Bundeskanzler hat gesehen und das
ist meine persönliche Meinung dass man
dem russischen Präsidenten nicht trauen
kann und dass die Ukraine vollkommen im
Recht ist
sie nicht derselben Meinung
wir haben lange an den deutschen Türen
und Fenstern geklopft damit wir gehört
werden und haben immer wieder betont
dass wir es mit nicht ganz normalen
Menschen zu tun haben
und es ist sehr schwierig etwas zu
verhandeln mit diesen nicht ganz
normalen Menschen
einfach deshalb weil sie das eine
versprechen und gleich darauf ganz
anders handeln
letztendlich sind es Terroristen die
selbst nicht wissen was sie zum Schluss
haben wollen
jeden Tag verhindern sie ihre Ziele je
nach Lust und Laune und deswegen denke
ich dass der Bundeskanzler sich mehr in
das Thema eingearbeitet hat und das
beeinflusst entsprechend auch die
Aktivitäten der Regierung
das beeinflusst auch die Hilfen an die
Ukraine
und letztendlich wurde von der deutschen
Seite eingesehen dass es gerechter sein
wird dass wir genug Hilfe bekommen
die Ukraine bringt die meisten Opfer
heutzutage weil der Krieg auf unserem
Gebiet stattfindet ja es ist ja ein
großes Ziel ein notwendiges Ziel dass
der Terror auf unserem Gebiet
eingestellt werden muss
die Deutschen waren schon immer
pragmatisch und letztendlich kämpfen wir
im Interesse von ganz Europa bzw
unmittelbar von Deutschland
und das Misstrauen gegenüber Russland
und ein tieferes Verständnis führen
letztendlich dazu dass sowohl der
Bundeskanzler als auch die deutsche
Gesellschaft letztendlich
übereingekommen sind was die
Einschätzung des Krieges betrifft
und davon profitiert er selbst und die
deutsche Gesellschaft
wir müssen letztendlich die Krisen
selbst bewältigen die durch diese
Untaten von Russland verursacht wurden
und die Krisen können besser bewältigt
werden wenn man der Gesellschaft erklärt
was der Grund dafür ist und dass man
sich zusammenschließen muss
verliert wenn Europa verliert dann ist
das ein Verlust für alle Ukraine
das kostet sie wahrscheinlich viel Kraft
acht Monate dauert dieser Krieg jetzt
schon haben Sie noch Kraft
ja selbstverständlich sehr viel woher
kommt diese Kraft
es gibt Objektive Umstände
das ist unser Haus
das ist das was uns gehört
Europa ist wunderschön die ganze Welt
ist wunderschön und vielfältig aber wir
fühlen uns überall woanders als Gäste
als Einwanderer
ich denke die Ukrainer verstehen dass er
gut genauso wie ihr uns besser verstehen
das ist nicht der erste bewaffnete
Konflikt in der Welt und jeder der vor
solchen Konflikten geflohen ist versteht
das ganz genau
in Europa werden alle sehr herzlich
aufgenommen
Europa macht die Türen auf für
ukrainische Bürger und ich bin dafür
dankbar
ich bin dankbar Polen den baltischen
Länder Deutschland
trotzdem fühlt man sich bei euch wie
Gäste
jeder Mensch hat das Recht etwas eigenes
zu haben
das ist das eine
zum zweiten fühlt man sich frei man muss
frei sein
man hat das Leben geschenkt bekommen
das gibt nur ein Leben dass man leben
kann und man muss in diesem Leben die
eigene Wahl machen wie man lebt und es
verteidigen
zum dritten befinden sich auch die
Gräber unserer Vorfahren unserer
Verwandten hier auf unserem Boden und
auf den Grabsteinen stehen die Namen
unserer Verwandten
wir fühlen uns diesem Land viel näher
als jedem anderen in der Welt unsere
Emotionen sind mit diesem Land verbunden
unser Lachen unser weinen
ich denke wir müssen das in uns behalten
und das ist alles was wir besitzen
deshalb schöpfen wir daraus auch unsere
Kraft weiterzukämpfen und
selbstverständlich müssen wir auch
unsere Kraft auftanken in diesem Krieg
und diese Kraft kommt aus der Wahrheit
wir wissen das Besatzer zu uns gekommen
sind sie nehmen uns schon seit Jahren
etwas Weg unsere Menschen unsere Gebiete
unsere Ruhe zufrieden und wir spüren
dass wir im Recht sind
daher schöpfen wir auch unsere Kraft wir
sind nicht in Russland oder woanders der
Krieg findet hier in der Ukraine statt
und das sieht die ganze Welt
einige verschließen noch die Augen
gegenüber den Tatsachen
einige in Russland haben noch Angst die
Augen aufzumachen und die Wahrheit zu
erfahren
ich würde sagen die Bürger Russland sind
blind
sie sind
sie versperren sich gegen die Wahrheit
sie wollen nichts hören und nicht sehen
aber die Wahrheit ist wie Wasser und
Wasser findet immer seinen Weg und wird
sie erreichen
das sind die besten Argumente um für das
eigene Land zu kämpfen
das ist meine Meinung
wie es mir smalltritt na was ach so bin
da die ganze Welt schaut auf sie ist das
nicht eine große Bürde wirkt das nicht
die Gefahr dass der Anspruch an sie zu
groß ist slys
[Musik]
entschuldigung ich habe die Frage nicht
verstanden
die ganze Welt schaut darauf was
Präsident selenski macht was Präsident
selensky sagt sie hören ihm zu ihre
Argumente sind wichtig alles hängt von
Ihnen ab
ich verspüre diese große Verantwortung
und das ist meine Rolle als Anführer
eines großen Landes
leider wer ist täglich das ist leider
oder zum Glück so wahrscheinlich eher
leider dass wir ohne solche
Herausforderungen wie Krieg sehr lange
brauchen um als Oberhaupt eines Landes
sei es Bundeskanzler oder
Ministerpräsident zu verstehen zu
begreifen was die Wahl des Volkes
bedeutet
es gibt kaum jemanden der unsere
Verantwortung richtig einschätzen kann
welche Philosophie dahinter steckt
mehr
der Krieg liegt diesen nachfrei
ist dran
um zu verstehen was leadership bedeutet
die wichtig das ist die Einheit des
Landes zu verteidigen damit die Nation
überlebt dieses Volk diese Nation mit
all diesem Reichtum der an die nächsten
Generationen weitergegeben werden kann
mit der Kultur mit der Sprache
das muss überleben ich kann jetzt nicht
das ist sehr wichtig
[Musik]
ja ja ich verspüre eine sehr starke
Unterstützung in der Gesellschaft
wir haben mutige Menschen wir haben
tapfere Soldaten
Anspannung wenn ich merke dass die Welt
eine schnelle Reaktion erwartet und nur
Siege erwartet
keiner verliert gern
keiner will selbst als Verlierer
dastehen
das sind natürlich große Risiken wenn
Menschen getötet werden
Muster
bei mir kommen im Krieg zu gewinnen muss
man viele Menschen Opfern viele Menschen
sterben dabei
und wir wollen uns nicht teilen in
Verlierer und Gewinner
wenn wir gewinnen dann ist das ein Sieg
für das ganze Land und wir wollen diesen
Sieg mit so wenigen von die nur möglich
erreichen ja aber
wir die Ukraine können uns nicht leisten
zu verlieren das ist eine Frage des
Überlebens für uns
Andreas
ich verstehe sehr sehr gut die
Verantwortung die auf meinen Schultern
liegt
man kann nicht nur ein Staatsoberhaupt
sein wenn im Land alles gut läuft
Stabilität im Land ist immer gut
andererseits wurde ich auch gewählt und
ich muss dadurch
als der Krieg anfing haben sie den Stil
der Verhandlungen auf internationaler
Ebene stark verändert sie haben
deutliche Kritik an Leuten geäußert sie
sind wahrscheinlich der erste in dieser
Position der ohne Krawatte Auftritt
haben sie das so geplant oder ist das
spontan entstanden
ich war schon immer so ein Mensch
ich war schon immer auch
zufriedenszeiten sehr offen sehr direkt
und ich habe immer gedacht dass die
Wahrheit besser ist als die Lüge sie
dringt schneller durch
selbstverständlich
in der Diplomatie gibt es auch Wahrheit
aber es gibt auch etwas Arglist wo sind
die Spielregeln und wenn ein gutes
Ergebnis erreicht wird so ist das
natürlich auch ein Verdienst der
Diplomatie und ein sie
vor dieser groß angelegten Invasion in
der Friedenszeit habe ich versucht mich
nach den Regeln der Diplomatie zu
verhalten und alles offen zu
kommunizieren was nicht immer möglich
war
erst nach der Invasion habe ich versucht
mit anderen Staatsoberhäuptern zu
kommunizieren die sie es verdienen
ich hatte keine Zeit gehabt um mich zu
verbeugen oder um mich ständig zu
bedanken oder für eine öffentliche
Diplomatie wenn Sie so wollen
ich habe immer direkt gefragt kannst du
mir helfen oder nicht
und ich habe versucht auch andere
Staatsoberhäupter zu überzeugen oder von
ihnen zu erfahren wo ich falsch liege
das war allerdings immer ein Dialog
ich bin immer für einen Dialog und nicht
für ein Ultimatum
und das ist ein Dialog mit einem
greifbaren
ergebniszeit zum Überlegen nächstes Jahr
bekomme ich deine Antwort
wir haben keine Zeit zu verlieren
und diese Entscheidungen werden uns ja
vom Krieg vorgegeben und aufgezwungen
wir haben keine Zeit
jede Minute müssen wir raketeneinschläge
erwarten und es sind Menschenleben die
wir schützen müssen
je schneller ein Ergebnis eine Reaktion
kommt desto mehr leben können wir
erhalten und
Opfer vermeiden
das ist mein Hauptziel
sie reagieren immer sehr schnell auf
Situationen sie nehmen ihr iPhone und
sprechen etwas hinein überlegen Sie sich
das vorher haben sie einen Stab der Sie
berät
ich habe keinen Stab
ich habe einige Menschen einige Personen
die gemeinsam mit mir in einem Team
arbeiten
sie können mir helfen zum Beispiel
richtige Worte zu finden wir machen das
gemeinsam
das ist ja nicht so dass jemand mir
zuarbeitet und ich trete dann mit der
fertigen Rede auf nein das sind vor
allem meine eigenen Gedanken und unsere
gemeinsamen Ideen wie wir gemeinsam
reagieren sollten
das ist eine schnelle reaktionsstruppe
und wir behandeln zusammen alle Fragen
Wirtschaftsfragen
stromversorgungsangelegenheiten bis hin
zur Politik und Diplomatie
ist von all den Staatsmänner der Welt
wer hilft Ihnen wer ist ihnen nah
am bliese
meinen sie die Helfer oder rein
menschlich
ich meine Hilfe auf der menschlichen
Ebene nicht auf der finanziellen Ebene
natürlich sind da die stärksten Länder
die die Ihnen am meisten helfen können
aber auf der menschlichen Ebene gibt es
Politiker die ihnen nahestehen und
helfen
ich fühle mich Johnson sehr verbunden
Johnson duda mit den Oberhäuptern von
Lettland Litauen und Emanuel macron
er sagt mir immer schreib mir auf
WhatsApp oder ruf mich einfach an
das sind diejenigen Präsidenten mit
denen ich tatsächlich nicht nach
irgendwelchen protokollregeln spreche
sondern von jetzt auf gleich spontan das
hat sich so ergeben ich kann das nicht
erklären warum das so ist
es ist auch ihre Einstellung zu Ukraine
und das sind auch persönliche
Beziehungen zwischen uns
so kam es auch zwischen mir und Draghi
mit Mario dragel
das hat sich so entwickelt
in einem Krieg entstehen viele Probleme
man hat viele Probleme zu bewältigen als
Staatsoberhaupt
ich bin ja für strategische Fragen
zuständig für die Taktik ist mein Team
zuständig
und ein Krieg insbesondere ein Krieg
gegen Russland gegen ein großes
kompliziertes Land verlangt von uns
schnelle sofortige Lösungen
Mikromanagement im gewissen Sinne
und die Hälfte meines Kopfes beschäftigt
sich mit der Strategie
die andere Hälfte des Gehirns muss
ständig darüber nachdenken welche
Schritte wir taktisch vornehmen
alle unsere Schritte waren Antworten auf
die Schritte des Gegners
und in dieser Taktik ist es sehr wichtig
wer an deiner Seite steht schnelle
Lieferungen schnelle
Diskussionen über neue Terrorangriffe
des Gegners zum Beispiel über
irgendwelche Erkenntnisse unserer
Geheimdienste
alles setzt voraus dass wir uns nicht
auf einem normalen diplomatischen
Parkett bewegen sondern uns in einer Art
neuen diplomatischen Ebene verständigen
und so etwas gab es in der Welt früher
gar nicht
weil ich oder die Personen die ich
genannt habe besonders sind sondern weil
das der Krieg so uns aufgezwungen hat
so ist das schneller
wir können uns miteinander schneller
kurzfristiger verständigen
selbstverständlich haben wir pflegen wir
noch diplomatische Beziehungen zum
US-Präsidenten zum Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz
und sie sind genauso fest wie unsere
Beziehungen zu den Ländern die ich
bereits oben genannt habe
aber diese Eifer und Diplomatie hat mich
sehr sehr in den ersten Kriegstagen
unterstützt
ich konnte diese Menschen diese
Präsidenten wie du dabei Bedarf auch
nachts anrufen
und der US-Präsident beiden ist der
erste der nach der Invasion nach dem
Beginn der Invasion mich angerufen hat
ich glaube das war um 6 Uhr früh oder
etwas um diese Zeit
viele haben mir auch ihr Mitgefühl
mitgeteilt auch die slowakische
Präsidentin chaputova und viele anderen
ich will keine Namen hier unterschlagen
alle Staatsoberhäupter haben uns
unterstützt aber die iphone-diplomatie
hat sich dabei als sehr effizient und
unabdingbar gezeigt
now iPhone Diplomaten
auch auf persönlicher nicht nur auf
politischer Ebene ist als dieser immer
Einschlag hier direkt im Zentrum von
Kiew war mit wem haben Sie da als erstem
gesprochen
ja das war natürlich etwas ganz
Schreckliches
unser Feind führt solche Terrorangriffe
immer wieder
unter den ersten die sich bei mir danach
gemeldet haben war entweder du da oder
Bundeskanzler Scholz oder Emmanuel
macron
ich weiß nicht in welche Reihenfolge das
genau war weil ich nach diesem
Raketenangriff ungefähr zehn elf Anrufe
von anderen Präsidenten
Staatsoberhäuptern hatte
Justin todo von Präsident beiden und
anderen
hintereinander weg 10 11 oder mehr
Anrufe
aber sie reagieren sehr schnell und das
ist ein wichtiger Faktor
sie haben mich zum Bundeskanzler gefragt
wie unsere Beziehungen sich verändert
haben
sie haben sich sehr schnell geändert
herr Scholz hat sich schnell gemeldet
und es war für mich sehr wichtig dass
die G7 Staaten sich selbst sehr schnell
darüber verständigen
und Deutschland ist ja einer der
führenden Staaten unter den gesieben und
hat gerade den G7 Vorsitzenden
alle G7 Staaten haben uns Mut gemacht
uns unterstützt
das
wenn der Bundeskanzler sich dazu anders
verhalten hätte so hätte dieses Treffen
auch zehn Tage später stattfinden können
es wurde sofort einberufen und das ist
sehr erfreulich und das prägt unsere
Beziehungen heute
[Musik]
ich würde mir wünschen dass wir diese
Beziehungen nicht schleifen lassen
Europa hat seine Angst vor Russland noch
nicht ganz abgelegt
es kommt als Reaktion wie würden die
Russen darauf reagieren
was sagt Putin dazu
was passiert wenn Putin eines Tages
nicht mehr da ist
und das sind die Sorgen von Europa
der Krieg in der Ukraine ist eine Frage
der Initiative
in den ersten Kriegstagen hatten die
Russen die Initiative ergriffen
es war für uns schwer sehr schwer
ja unsere Armeen war nicht zu
vergleichen und die Stärke unserer
Armeen war ja ganz unterschiedlich
und nun hat sich auch die Lage geändert
und wir sind am Zug wir greifen an und
die russische Armee kann auf dem
Schlachtfeld nicht erreichen
deswegen werden wir eingeschüchtert
es ertönen immer wieder Drohungen uns
gegenüber
das ist eine Art Erpressung weil
Russland selbst ja die Initiative hatte
und sagen wir viele Jahre lang von
Europa geduldet wurde
daher auch die Drohungen mit dem
Atomwaffeneinsatz
Europa hat bei Russland gebettelt
letztendlich müssen alle Länder gleich
sein und auf Augenhöhe stehen
und das wird den Russen keiner
verzeiheniopter ruski da senden das wird
keiner vergessen dass sie getan haben
und es ist unzulässig dass ein Land der
ganzen Welt diktiert wie die andere Welt
zu leben hat ob sie genug Wärme bekommt
oder nicht
alternativlos an der gasnadel zu hängen
das ist unzulässig das darf nicht seiner
wir sind in einer neuen Etappe des
Krieges sie haben großen Erfolg sie
genießen große Unterstützung besteht
nicht das Risiko dass dies Russland
provoziert dass wir erleben dass sie
Atomwaffen einsetzen das besorgt die
deutschen momentan sehr nah takaya
Reaktor
[Musik]
ja das Risiko besteht
aber
das Risiko wird durch eine schwache
Position Deutschlands überhaupt nicht
erhöht
wenn ihr meint verstehen Sie was ich
meine jetzt
und dieses Risiko kann Europa insgesamt
durch seinen Standpunkt gar nicht
beeinflussen
die Russen werden dann Angst haben die
eine oder die andere Waffe einzusetzen
wenn alle in Europa eindeutig ihre
eigene Stärke erkennen
wenn sie begreifen dass sie mit nichts
zu erpressen sind
wenn jemand ein Besatzer ist dann muss
er ganz klar politisch isoliert bleiben
niemand spricht davon sich so zu
verhalten wie die russendes tun auf
keinen Fall
er benimmt sich wie ein Terrorist aber
europa darf sich nicht zu verhalten
man darf keine Schwäche zeigen gegenüber
der russischen Führung
es ist klar er wird sich alles Stück für
Stück nehmen und
immer mehr Schwächen und eine schwache
Position gegenüber Russland wird ihn in
die Lage versetzen jede Waffe
einzusetzen
Folgen verspürt er sieht sich die Folgen
der besetzten Krümmern
es hat sehr oberflächliche Sanktionen
gegeben lassen sie uns offen sein und
das hat ihn nicht gestoppt
man hat ihn gewarnt und diese Warnung
war offensichtlich nicht stark genug
es hat keine angemessene Antwort gegeben
und darin besteht das Problem
er hatte ein Teil von unserem Donbass
annektiert
was hat er als Antwort bekommen nichts
die verabschiedeten Sanktionen waren
nicht stark genug und er ging noch einen
Schritt weiter
schauen Sie was weiter in dem
Energiesektor passiert ist auf alle
seine Schritte nach vorne hat Europa mit
entsprechenden Schritten zurückreagiert
man hat das Gefühl gehabt man hat sich
mit Russland angenähert aber all das
waren Schritte zurück
denn in dieser Umarmung wird Russland
euch einfach erdrücken
beides das Ziel dieser Führung ist
ich spreche dabei nicht über die
Menschen ich spreche über die Führung
leider wurden die Menschen komplett
einer Gehirnwäsche unterzogen sie sind
durch die russischen Medien Irre geführt
die Reintegration wird lange brauchen
aber es ist ihr Anliegen ich meine jetzt
die Führung von Russland daher wird er
die Atomwaffen nur dann einsetzen wenn
er ganz genau weiß dass es nach dem
Einsatz keine Folgen für ihn geben wird
genauso funktioniert es warum haben wir
die ganze Zeit vor der Invasion von
präventiv Sanktionen gesprochen
präventiv Sanktionen vor diesem
angekündigten Raketenbeschuss warum hat
er hundertmal geschossen weil in die
nicht schmerzen er spürt aber dass er
das Vertrauen seiner eigenen
Gesellschaft verliert er kann keine
Erfolge auf dem Schlachtfeld vorweisen
er muss sich rechtfertigen
deshalb hat er 100 mal auf uns
geschossen hundertmal
wenn man aber vorher Putin klargemacht
hätte schau du hast dein Volk deine
Nation Irre geführt du hast uns Irre
geführt wir hatten energieverträge
gehabt und jetzt hast du dein Vertrauen
fast verloren verspielt wir werden mit
dir nicht mehr verhandeln Ende
die niemand spricht mehr mit dir wir
werden keine Verträge mehr mit dir
schließen
du willst nicht zu normalen Preisen
Energieressourcen nach Europa verkaufen
du willst jetzt Preise hochschrauben
wir werden das verkraften wir werden den
Winter überwinden
die europäischen Staats- und
Regierungschefs haben sich versammelt
und haben beschlossen wie wir einander
helfen um diesen Winter zu überstehen
nicht so wie es mit der Pandemie war das
ist ein gutes Land deshalb bekommt es
den Impfstoff ein weniger gutes Land
muss weiter warten
lasst uns zusammen diesen Winter
durchstehen das ist eine Aufgabe für
ganz Europa das war's
und er wird euch nicht auf die Knie
zwingen wir müssen uns zusammenreißen
wir müssen das überstehen
wenn Putin verstehen würde dass keiner
mit ihm sprechen wird dass er isoliert
bleibt dann würde auch die russische
Gesellschaft verstehen dass sie den
Menschen zum Präsidenten gewählt hat der
alle mit Atomwaffen bedroht
er hat die Ukraine angegriffen wir haben
Sanktionen beschlossen aber er geht
weiter er droht mit Atomwaffen und
deswegen müssen wir auch ganz klar sagen
liebe Bürger der Russischen Föderation
euer Präsident spricht vom Einsatz von
Atomwaffen wir können nicht mit ihm
sprechen und ihr werdet alle darunter
leiden wir werden uns alle von eurem
Land isolieren weil wir nichts mit
Terroristen zu tun haben wollen das ist
gerecht wenn ihr zu einem Dialog bereit
seid ohne Bedrohungen ohne
Maschinengewehre auf eurem Territorium
verlassen sie das Fremde Territorium
hört auf unsere Menschen zu erschießen
ihr ermordet einfach Menschen
wenn alle in seinem Umfeld entschuldigen
sie Welpen sind nicht einmal Hunde sie
sind einfach Welpen wenn jeder 50 Gramm
Wodka trinkt und sofort schreit morgen
werden wir Atomwaffen einsetzen was soll
das überhaupt
verstehen sie nicht dass das große Angst
in Europa und in Deutschland provoziert
denen die sich um ihre Sicherheit sorgen
was können sie denn sagen
sie müssen ihre starke Position immer
wieder unter Beweis stellen
wenn diese Stärke von ihm gespürt wird
dann wird er keine Atomwaffen einsetzen
er wird Angst haben seine Macht zu
verlieren
dann wird seine eigene Bevölkerung ihn
auffressen sorry für diese harten Worte
aber die Russen werden das Hören und sie
werden es verstehen
er muss Angst haben nicht wir Europa mit
dieser langjährigen Geschichte und wir
zittern vor ihm warum hat die gesamte
Welt Angst vor einer Person
200 Länder sitzen in der Vollversammlung
der un- und lassen sich gefallen dass
ein Mensch der ganzen Welt droht aber
das ist nur ein Mensch
wir haben gesagt sie sind nicht mehr
bereit mit Putin zu reden ja mit wem
wollen sie reden wie kann der Krieg
beendet werden wie können wir Frieden
erreichen
wir sind bereit mit allen zu reden die
den Frieden wollen auch mit der
Russischen Föderation
seit meinem ersten Arbeitstag in diesem
Amt war ich bereit mit Putin zu sprechen
ich habe auch den Kontakt gewollt und
gesucht
man hat mir Ultimaten gestellt ich habe
um ein Gespräch gebeten ich habe
Deutschland und Frankreich und die USA
angesprochen und immer wieder gefragt
wie können wir mit Russland etwas
vereinbaren wenn Russland nicht einmal
mit uns sprechen will
nicht am Telefon gar nicht
zwei Jahre lang habe ich diese Versuche
unternommen vor der Invasion und die
Russen wollen mit mir nicht sprechen
sie haben gesagt wir werden
einmarschieren und Schluss
sind mit uns zu sprechen
wer ist der denn
er hat Menschen umgebracht sie haben
Kinder vergewaltigt seine Soldaten haben
Kinder vergewaltigt
er sagt wir haben es uns alles
ausgedacht
das kann nicht sein die Ukraine haben es
selbst angerichtet er sagt das und
greift direkt das Zentrum unserer
Hauptstadt mit 100 Raketen an das
Zentrum von Kiew servus
und wartet darüber das ist Narzissmus in
Reinsdorf Form es geht von ihm aus
jetzt
am 22 juni als der Zweite Weltkrieg
ausgebrochen ist wurde Kiew mit Bomben
angegriffen
und was wurde gebombt es wurden 20 oder
22 Phosphorbomben im Gebiet von Kiew
abgeworfen
22 Phosphorbomben im Zweiten Weltkrieg
das große bolschewistische Werk unsere
Flughäfen der Bahnhof und die Kraftwerke
22 Bomben am ersten Tag des Kriegs
und vor zwei Tagen waren es 100 Raketen
die auf unsere Infrastruktur unsere
Kraftwerke abgefeuert wurden
damals wurde unsere Kadettenschule
angegriffen jetzt ist das die Uni in
Kiel
nein die Geschichte ist ganz einfach er
schaltet den Strom und die Wärme aus er
schaltet es mit den Raketen aus
er zeigt seiner Gesellschaft schaut das
was euch gesagt wird dass wir auf dem
Schlachtfeld keine Erfolge haben das
sind Lügen schaut was ich mache
ganz genau dass seine Soldaten schwächer
sind als unsere Soldaten
deshalb tötet er unbewaffnete Zivilisten
wenn seine Soldaten unsere Soldaten
nicht überwältigen können ermorden Sie
unsere Leute die unbewaffnet sind so
einfach ist es
doch na Barut und das habe ich ihn
malatabı aber dieser Mensch ist nicht
normal ist nicht bei Sinnen und er
versteht nicht dass es uns vereint dass
er uns stärker macht
es kann auch sein dass er überhaupt
nicht begreift dass er mit jedem
Raketenangriff alle verhandlungsschancen
zunichte macht
putin ist für uns für unser Land ein
Sammelbegriff ein Inbegriff eines
Terroristen und wir sagen immer wieder
wir sind für den Frieden wir betonen
immer wieder wir werden mit Russland
sprechen aber nicht mit ihm damals
stressige budim galer
aber mit wem irgendeiner wird für ihn
kommen auf jeden Fall wir sind dabei
jetzt sie schauen sich wahrscheinlich
genau an was in Russland passiert was
ist ihr Szenario wie kann dieser Krieg
beendet werden
amtierende Präsident kann durchaus
diesen Krieg beenden
kann versuchen sein Leben zu erhalten
indem er seine Truppen einfach aus dem
Land abzieht
noch nicht zu einem diplomatischen
Prozess er kann in der Geschichte eine
Art Pause einlegen
denn solange die russischen Truppen auf
unserem Territorium sind wird es keine
Pause geben
es wird weiter eine partisanbewegung
geben das ist eine Tatsache
weil die Menschen auf der Krim nicht
zufrieden sind
er mobilisiert dort Menschen ukrainische
Staatsbürger
zuerst hat er ihnen die Pässe gegeben
jetzt mobilisiert er sie
nicht möglich die Gesellschaft komplett
zu verändern das ist für ihn eine fremde
Gesellschaft ein fremdes Land
er hat im Prinzip ein fremdes Haus
betreten hat es verunreinigt
er hat vergewaltigt er hat getötet und
er kann jederzeit seine Truppen abziehen
er kann einfach Befehlen dass unsere
Menschen nicht mehr getötet werden
und Sie denken dass er das macht
ich versuche jetzt eine Vision
darzulegen und sie können selbst
einschätzen ob sie zut oder nicht
man hat ja gesehen dass einige
Versorgungswege gaslieferwege schon
gesprengt wurden
angegriffen
weil Russland versteht dass sie dafür
verantwortlich gemacht werden
deswegen wird das nicht gemacht
vielleicht wird in Russland auf einmal
etwas gesprengt oder einfach kaputt
gemacht das ist ganz ihr Stil
sie werden alles unternehmen um unser
ganzes Transportsystem unsere Pipelines
zu beschädigen
danach wird Putin Europa sagen
es gibt keine andere Möglichkeit als
nord-stream 2 in Betrieb zu nehmen
und Putin wird immer wieder betonen dass
Deutschland diese Möglichkeit nach wie
vor hat
Deutschland soll als Lobbyist für die
Inbetriebnahme von nordstream 2
auftreten und wir müssen das immer
wieder betonen
wir müssen das allen Reportern und allen
Massenmedien immer wieder klar machen
[Musik]
wenn Russland weiterhin die
Energieversorgung von Europa immer
wieder außer Betrieb setzt dann wird
Russland immer wieder darauf bestehen
dass Nord Stream 2 in Betrieb genommen
wird
und das soll Europa verweigern
wir verstehen doch sehr gut wie die
weiteren Schritte von Putin sein werden
es gibt eine Logik darin warum wird
jetzt die Ukraine der Wärme bereut warum
militärische auseinandersetz
warum wird ein Atomkraftwerk besetzt
warum wurden dort 500 Soldaten
stationiert
worin besteht der Zweck des Ganzen
es soll ja vom Strom genommen werden
warum
dadurch
die ganze Zeit dass es eine spezielle
Militäroperation ist
er vernichtet angeblich irgendwelche
Faschisten so nennt er uns
hat ein Atomkraftwerk damit zu tun
hast
wir werden vom Strom abgeschaltet
Putin versucht Menschen einzuschüchtern
damit sie fliehen damit sie auf die
Straße gehen und verlangen dass sich
Putin beruhigen soll
unsere Armee soll aufgeben wir sollen
kapitulieren
das ist alles sehr primitiv
na das ist die Situation jetzt
so wird es in zwei Monaten sein Europa
wird vor der Frage stehen woher die
Wärme kommen soll woher die notwendigen
Gasmengen nehmen
noch eine kleine Frage
oder zwei sie sagten wir haben uns
verspätet
dieser Krieg hat die Welt stark
verändert wie sehen Sie die Welt der
Zukunft in welcher Welt werden wir in
Zukunft leben
es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten
die starken Länder die auch politisch
stark sind die eine führende Position in
der Welt einnehmen
wenn die Welt uns die Unterstützung
verweigert ist zulässt das Russland uns
besiegt
wir werden natürlich bis zum Schluss
kämpfen bis zum letzten Kämpfer
dann wird klar sein dass das eine
Möglichkeit ist
und zwar nicht nur für Russland sondern
auch für andere Länder
es besteht das Risiko dass die Grenzen
in der Welt einmal verschoben werden
das wird eindeutig zu einer Welle von
solchen Grenzverschiebungen kommen
eine große Welle denn es gibt einige
Länder auf verschiedenen Kontinenten ich
will jetzt keine Schuldigen benennen
insgesamt wird die Welt daran schuld
sein dass die Welt das hier zugelassen
hat
Perspektive sehr warm mir budvin Award
wir haben heute Bezug auf den Zweiten
Weltkrieg genommen und das wird genauso
wie in der Tschechoslowakei sein
man hat bei Hitler etwas nachgegeben
Zugeständnisse gemacht und das wird
genauso weltweit passieren und das wird
natürlich zu einem Weltkrieg führen
zweifellos
und ich denke die zukünftige Welt wird
eine Welt von großen Monopolen sein
monopoli es geht aber natürlich nicht
darum dass die rechte ganz abgeschafft
werden von kleinländern nein aber die
größeren stärkeren Länder werden die
kleineren in Griff bekommen und
unterdrücken
sie werden die Welt unter sich aufteilen
es gibt aber auch eine andere
Möglichkeit ein anderes Szenario
jeder Mensch in dieser Welt unabhängig
von der Größe seines Landes von der
Bewaffnung seiner Armee der sich darüber
bewusst ist dass er genauso geschützt
ist dieselben Rechte hat wie jeder
andere Mensch in dieser Welt
es gibt die Ukraine als Beispiel
unabhängig davon wie groß Russland ist
die gesamte Welt wird sich an deine
Seite stellen wenn Menschenrechte
verletzt werden
die zwei möglichen Szenarien aus meiner
Sicht what is your wo ich tendiere er
zum zweiten Modell zum zweiten Szenario
der gleichen Rechte und dergleichen
Freiheiten
ja aber die Welt hat selbst die Wahl zu
treffen
vielen Dank noch eine kleine letzte
Frage ich sehe sie jedes Mal in diesem
T-Shirt ich habe viele wie viele ca 20
20 WoW
und wissen Sie warum
das kann ich Ihnen sagen
ich hatte zu Beginn des Krieges zwei
solche T-Shirts und einen Fleecepullover
da ich habe ihn später weggegeben in
London auf der Versteigerung
und dann haben Soldaten wie ein solches
T-Shirt geschenkt mit einem Dankeschön
von der zweiten Brigade dann bekam ich
noch eins
ukrainski
und eines Tages haben auch unsere
ukrainischen Hersteller angefangen
selbst zu produzieren und sie mir zu
schenken damit ich ihre Produkte trage
ich habe Zuge okay später musste ich sie
zurückhalten alle wollten dass sich ihre
T-Shirts tragen so ungefähr
ich danke Ihnen sehr
ich habe überhaupt keinen Mangel an
Kleidung